50 seconds of logos the hell is this a
marble moving Comcast left own uh
peacock Andre is all the way out the
suburbs which means he either drove uber
tour camp it here for some reason
doesn't stop right in front of his
destination you know I'd like to do
tomorrow and why are you crossing the
street instead of running in the
direction you were already going knowing
what we know later was pure me driving
around this neighborhood on the off
chance that somebody like Andre would be
walking around here tonight
if so what a lucky break this is an orgy
of evidence that this is a hipster
apartment patent leather furniture check
exposed brick wall section yep old black
and white art hell yeah
manicured kitchen with probably organic
herb growing of course tiny hipster dog
on an orthopedic bed you got it
goddamn this movie is already lamping
the fuck out of some lamps there are
five of those in this tiny studio
apartment didn't know him black yeah why
would Rose say no to this having Chris
believed that her parents don't know
he's black immediately raises his
suspicions which is totally antithetical
to their plan
sube conjures up horrible Rinku memories
within its first 10 minutes stuff the
deer came across the street from the
left to the right so there's no way it
could dislodge the passenger-side mirror
apparently the magical deer also briefly
took control of the AC in the car
considering it went from off to on then
back to off within a matter of seconds
nearly a full minute of chris slowly
walking towards a dead deer so in the
future the number to call is animal
control services and seriously they had
a wreck on a public road that might have
affected traffic this asshole cop
seriously has too much to do in the
sleepy town to be annoyed by automobile
accidents he wasn't driving
I didn't ask who was driving I asked to
see his ID I'm going to go ahead and
remove a sin for the scene because well
it's easy to think this is just a
typical horror movie protagonist hit a
deer cliche that offers the opportunity
for a scene with incredible subtext yeah
why that doesn't make any sense you find
out later this is a ruse to ensure Rose
has Chris's complete trust but those
Rose really need this moment to endear
herself to Chris and she's been working
him for several months by now but I'm
telling ya I do not like the deer I'm
sick of it some I see a dead deer on the
side of the road I think to myself
that's a start you're shadowing also
discount Cubs manager drill matin Jeremy
this res is no brother
fairy stories expositional photography
my mother loved her kitchens we keep a
piece of her in here Jesus Jordan Peele
so expertly dropped subtle hints about
the overall reveal that you think he's a
seasoned veteran director but this is
his first movie for that I'm definitely
taking a cinema also having said that
this line makes no sense considering
Dean doesn't go on to say which actual
piece of his mom that they keep in here
so damn it I got to give that sin right
back we hired Georgina and Walter to
help care for my parents funny thing is
they are my parents but we thought the
best use for them was to keep them
around the house and amp up the creepy
factor for all potential guests and
kidnap ease sent to this pun rated their
liquid cannon Oh tell me this isn't true
I feel lik about us as water okay is
this a made-up story because it doesn't
sound like one not Jeremy and Rose get
away with killing the liquor bottles
with water without anyone noticing after
all these years are the bottles still
here is the entrance to the tiny closet
open we later know that it contains
secrets about Rose's past so she
wouldn't leave it open and if Georgina
did it when the hell did she slip in
since Chris hasn't fallen asleep the
closet door thing is an interesting
detail in this movie but it doesn't make
any goddamn sense the first time it's
open movie is playing on our
expectations of horror movies with these
someone walks by quickly in the
background complete with a music stinger
trope but in the end it's still that
same trope an unnecessary jump-scare
moment in a movie that is already plenty
creepy
this is a precast part of the movie and
a great shot but why would grandpa
Walter be running in the dark woods at
night directly toward the house in full
groundskeeper clothing I know he's a
runner and wants to get some exercise
and all but this is when and how you do
it she realized how dangerous smoking is
character that was sitting in the dark
turn on the light as the protagonist
walks in cliche sit with me please so
this is the crux of the movie if Chris
doesn't go out for a late night smoke he
doesn't run into Missy and she doesn't
gain hypnotic control of it
the problem is what would they have done
if this didn't happen even that they
suspected he would they couldn't have
known he was going to sneak out that
night I mean the party's tomorrow what
if he avoided Missy for the next 12 to
15 hours a key focal point sometimes to
guide someone to a state of heightened
suggestibility I know this is a movie
and all but this movie's portrayal of
how hypnosis actually works like II can
but I don't mean to go through a movie
and keep removing sins and all that but
Daniel Kaluga Catherine Keener and
Jordan Peele are killing the scene I'm
removing three here probably would
remove more but on an asshole now you're
in this fuckin place it's like the
further but it gets high-definition TV
from a distance also the best way to
keep your hypnotized subject relaxed and
suggestible is to terrify the fuck out
of them
[Music]
in addition to being a housekeeper or
Georgina's other job is to provide the
movie 75% of its jump scares
Walter's Ben presumably chopping for a
while given the pile of wood beside him
but Chris doesn't hear him until its
plot convenient also yep it's a horror
movie
so wood is chopped despite a few rebels
this is still essentially the all the
bad guys driving black SUVs cliche so
all these people coming in at the same
time did they coordinate their arrival
to the party that's great super Gordon
loves Tigers Oh best I've ever seen ever
hands down will be expertly navigate to
the facade of going out of one's way to
not appear racist as still being racist
you didn't think you'd see this at a
fairly low-budget horror movie did you
this is a fancy party with rich people
at a fancy estate but they're serving
early times as the whiskey you can buy
that for $3 in a you scratch off ticket
this was just telling me how he felt
much more comfortable with my being nude
why is this couple even here obviously
since Chris is a man there is no need
for this couple to even bother with the
auction
since this woman's husband already had
the surgery now they could just be
friends coming to mingle at a party and
watch the auction but
considering that Logan act so strangely
wouldn't the Armitage's want to keep him
away for a couple reasons they've made
the irony of being a blind dog together
isn't lost on me
Steven root playing a blind dude and a
movie cliche this is a legitimately
creepy moment but why'd they stop
talking so quickly he's not even at the
top of the stairs and could easily hear
everything get completely quiet these
are the most obvious evil rich Body
Snatcher II motherfuckers ever also what
exactly makes them stop laughing and
talking right now they looking to hear
something that will give them more
information before they did on him this
is like the actors in The Truman Show
only Chris isn't being broadcast live to
millions of people find out later
Georgina is unplugging Chris's phone but
why didn't she just take the charger the
whole point is to make sure his phone
dies is this somehow subtler also a
movie wants me to believe that Chris a
millennial hipster has gone all day
without access to his phone also also he
plugged in the phone right when he got
up and it was still charging until right
before the party so how has the battery
run all the way down over the course of
the get-together was Georgina here using
up all the Jews by posting constant
instagrams she closed my phone Chris
plays the pronoun game so that rules
will have to ask what the hell she means
I think then mom it's good nearby in a
trance and she finished that up
damn it movie stop giving me excellent
performances that make me want to remove
since Joel credits so the secret weapon
against the body-snatching is a camera
flash but why wouldn't the Armitage's
already know that it's doing this for a
while right and if they did know that
why didn't they put up a big sign saying
no flash photography also why the hell
is Chris's camera using a flash outside
in the middle of a day anyway also it's
nice that Andres concerned about Chris
'''l but if he had a moment of clarity
wouldn't it be better to say I was
kidnapped and they forced an old white
dude inside me instead although I guess
that doesn't make a snappy movie title
and it's gonna sound weird but when he
came at me it felt like I knew so
luckily Chris needs to go talk about
some things with Rose after that
incident with Logan because Dean Arbutus
conducts the auction out in the open a
place we saw Chris stumble upon about 15
minutes ago why are they certain he
won't see this even if Rose is supposed
to keep it busy Monica what happening
whatever you want
how does Marnie know how long she needs
to distract Chris so the rich assholes
can do their asshole bingo auction I
mean they've got his picture out there
and everything so if he actually left
when he said he was going to he catch
them almost immediately I guess they've
already laid the hypnosis trap at
everything but seems like they went to a
lot of work
to make this a secret plan that can be
easily discovered hey how did he get
full battery power again he plugged the
phone in then after talking to Rod and
Georgina he took it with him so he could
snap the picture of Logan then they came
back inside for a second before taking a
walk
so the phone both charges immediately
and goes dead in less than a couple of
hours and is thus both magic and an
asshole who's that goal right now can
you go get my magic Chris opens the door
and finds a box and even though he knows
he needs to get the hell out of there
fast
he has overwhelming curiosity about the
box and amazingly enough he gets through
four innocuous pictures before finding
the one photo the calls roses honesty
into question also Chris ignored this
tiny closets open door earlier when he
couldn't sleep but now when he needs to
immediately leave he decides to explore
and whatever happened that these guys if
the Armitage azar selling these guys to
their rich buddies why aren't they also
at the auction today we lead actually
really why something wrong why even
bother with the act at this point
there's no way he's going to get the
leaf and we know Rose is in on it what's
the point this teacup has some pretty
amazing acoustics
not only is mom standing on the other
side of the room Chris isn't a physical
scrum shouldn't be able to hear much of
anything let alone a couple taps with a
spoon I absolutely love the parallel
between Chris and rock Chris's main
guilt in his life is not calling someone
when his mom didn't come home on time
rod is doing the exact same thing Chris
was doing the day his mom died Rob might
even know all the details of that story
and even subliminally Chris's story is
working on him now
I could probably remove all the sins of
this movie for being so much more than
what's on its surface I'm only going to
remove three because yeah I'm a dick rod
you just being repeating the mistake
Peter Parker makes in the amazing
spider-man this is a pretty
comprehensive review of Andres
disappearance and everything listed in
related searches makes sense except the
way too convenient family outrage search
canceled who the hell would use those
specific search terms also Andre
Hayworth brings up over 50 million
results for comparison if you googled
George Clooney right now you'd get a
little more than 35 million also under
this how to report missing persons page
the article is about how to feed a dog
and words are in bold like those are the
words Ron typed but he didn't movie or
Bing but mainly movie hoping to save on
space the Armitage's combine their game
room with their expositional hypnosis
room the Armitage's go with the tie down
method of keeping captives in place
rather than using Mississip gnosis which
works so perfectly super old timey TV is
somehow programmed to come on as soon as
chris wakes up even though
it's super old timing be home back on by
the way this video explained nothing
Broadway TSA yes-man
no art is a issue should be brought up
with the authorizing officer did Ron go
to the police station and start telling
everyone he was from the TSA if he's
reporting a missing person then why
would he make it seem like he was here
on TSA business see that's Andre
anywhere he's been missing for six
months and some affluent suburb and he
don't look so missing
rod shows this woman a picture of Andre
Logan but doesn't show her the many
websites looking for this guy and
showing that he is indeed missing may
not a work but still you'll be able to
see and hear when your body is doing but
your existence will be as a passenger
hmm this movie just got very Being John
Malkovich also and Catherine Keener is
in it too
let's let people some people want to be
stronger cooler come on you're high man
so most of these people just want to be
black because they think it's cool and
that's fun and this guy just wants
Chris's eyes and couldn't care less
about the skin color but why hasn't the
market expanded to white people or any
other kind of race as well surely
there's somebody who wants to be Zac
Efron or Rafael Nadal and by acting so
strangely they're not getting the cool
benefits from being black either so I'm
having a little trouble understanding
why one would spend millions of dollars
on this process also Jim's appreciation
of Chris's I was in the context of how
it was interpreted by his brain and
almost all that was about to go so Jim
for being an asshole Body Snatcher
participant but an extra for his faulty
logic a plain neurosurgeon Dean Armitage
practices brain surgery by in
candlelight why would you start any part
of the extremely delicate and expensive
procedure before getting the other
subject in here everything about Jeremy
putting Chris into this wheelchair
allows Chris to get a surprise attack on
Jeremy and holy SH this is exactly the
scenario by which cinemasins writes
scripts great reveal but put that back
in man that cup spoon thing is like your
only weakness
hmm tyranny also this guy is running
with deer antlers straight towards you
and you didn't hear that
look I know Chris is in a rough head
space right now but he's literally
watching all the evidence about these
people burn in front of it his
character's been shown as much too smart
to let that happen
asshole jeremy is somehow not dead after
getting bludgeoned and his head leaked a
huge pool of oil or evil or whatever
passes for that dude's blood also
awesome movie nearly tries to self at
the end by using a bad guy that's
definitely already dead comes back to
try to kill a protagonist cliche being
overload this is how Rose Scouts the
next candidates how did she find Chris
chris is a photographer or some note I
guess but not someone you probably be
able to goog I mean being easily Plus
unless the entire auction was rigged so
that Jim Hudson could win it there's no
real point in getting Chris unless it
was specifically for his eyes
five-second repeater
ready alright Rose can hear Chris hit
Georgina way the hell down at the end of
the goddamn driveway outside but missed
all that was happening just downstairs
did you say that for was it not subtly
explained in that video and through
context clues that the two grandparents
were twerking and Walter this actually
might be the worst part of the movie
which is a great testament to its
quality this was just desperately
calling 911 when he hit Georgina and got
interrupted a few seconds ago why isn't
he calling them again
just so we can get a last hurrah from
the queen of this movies jump scares
Chris survives this
I guess Rose decided to run down the
road on the off chance that Chris would
wreck the car why didn't she get in her
own car in the first place try and track
them down rather than heading for cover
in the dark woods Chris recalls his
training at the Prometheus school of
running away from things
damn grandpa god dammit also why why do
you need grandpa to run him down when
you have a king loaded weapon Rose
definitely sees this flash and knows
what flashes do to the subjects who have
undergone this procedure and even though
Walter says let me do it in that totally
not old white guy way that totally tells
us he's not Walter anymore Rose doesn't
see any reason to take caution man Rose
sure does have a killin boner II I mean
she could be calling for help instead of
trying to finish Chris off considering
she's dying and all holy Sh I'm taking a
sin off of this too
you know what would actually make a
great prequel the story of this kid how
you found me I'm TS
mother Hey haha that's hilarious
I'm laughing but I'm also giving soon to
the TSA being able to find somebody out
in the middle of nowhere with no clue to
this situation can handle I love this
line and this ending so much but they're
leaving all the dead people there call
somebody protect some evidence you've
been smart this whole movie keep
smarting
she crying hurry up and get in the
closet
hey she's all ready for this I asked for
my tie and they brought to you pina
colada
and I said no sauce no so now all of us
of all dynamic ears if you can't think
enough of it oh no no well most of the
world is caught and one day we will do
the cleaning
oh come on